we got another crazy chapter with more
insane reveals about Dragon Luffy Kuma
the most broken devil fruit there is in
more so make sure to stay tuned for this
one but first chill the parking within
and smash that like button if you enjoy
seeing these weekly chapter reviews and
want to keep them coming make this the
video you join the Naka if you haven't
already by subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications so you don't miss future
one piece videos and updates Bear In
Mind by hitting that one virtual button
you're actually helping me achieve my
insane goal of 2 Mill ion subscribers
here on YouTube and I'd be eternally
grateful for that and now without
further Ado let's jump into It spoilers
and all so this chapter chapter
1,11 is called dear Bonnie so we will
have more flashback but don't worry it's
worth it as we'll see one of the
craziest chapters now the color spread
for this chapter will be a dream come
true for Vega Punk fans we get Vega punk
in the middle Lilith and Pythagoras to
his right Atlas and Edison to his left
York's faing the background on the right
side and shaka's face in the back on the
left side and then Vega Force One in the
center this is a great one for Vega Punk
stands but onto the chapter itself and
it starts with a little flashback inside
of the flashback flash setion if you
will Kuma remembers one of his trips
with the Revolutionary Army in Goa
Kingdom Kuma mentions that he noticed
that dragons seemed to know a lot about
the country he even says crazy part here
that he visited a village outside the
country to observe a certain boy of
course we know that certain boy was none
other than his son monkey Luffy and this
is huge by the way we know he used to
look off into the distance in the
direction of his son but this takes her
to another level Dragon not only thought
of his son he'd even make the time to
observe him in secret now why if he
loved him so much clearly did he abandon
him and never meet him face to face well
believe it or not Oda will finally give
us that information in this one Dragon
says to Kuma keep talking if you want to
die pretty cool hearing Dragon talk like
that and Kuma asks why to which Dragon
replies a child is the parents weakness
end quote Kuma says he understands and
he won't look into that anymore so Oda
not only shows how much Dragon cares for
his son Luffy in this chapter Dragon
actually says it's because he cares
about his son so much that he keeps him
at a distance in other words Dragon
knows that Luffy would be in danger and
a Target if people knew Luffy was his
son and that Dragon loved him so he
keeps him at a distance all of this
Dragon time in the flashback makes me
excited that Dragon will be joining
forces with Luffy sooner rather than
later as I've been saying think about it
now he can't really use the excuse
anymore for not seeing Luffy because
Luffy is pretty much on the most wanted
list already so Dragon getting closer to
him shouldn't make him any more of a
Target thus dragon and Luffy will meet
up and join forces soon hopefully Oda
seems to be teasing him more and more
with each passing chapter and I for one
am hyped smash that like button if you
are too then for now we cut to the
normal flashback where the last chapter
ended Kuma entered Mount kbo and
observed Luffy by the way Luffy 16 years
old old at this point he's practicing a
secret attack and this is a very nice
touch and throwback to an iconic moment
that I'll get into shortly the move he's
practicing is his G noono AKA gum gum
battle axe yes the same attack that he
used to defeat arlong one of the most
iconic moments in one piece since that
was also one of the big moments of the
recent Ultra popular one piece live
action season 's timing seems pretty
purposeful here it's very cool to know
that Luffy spent so much time long ago
practicing this move and now we
appreciate that moment with arlong all
the more this is what I love about oda's
flashbacks they make us not only
appreciate the flashback but also other
moments in the story we appreciate them
more and in new ways suddenly Kuma gets
a call from the world government Luffy
hears the sound and this is the
interesting part senses a chilling
presence nearby but when he looks Kuma
is gone Luffy says um there must be some
really strong animal in this Forest that
I have yet to defeat end quote we won't
get into the fact that he wouldn't stand
a chance at defeating this animal yet
but it does sound like some pretty solid
observation hockey for a 16-year-old I
got to say it's also funny because Kuma
is looked at as a bear and that's why
his clone is called s bear so it fits
pretty perfectly so Kuma left Dawn
Island were told to complete World
Government orders we can see Kuma
helping a merchant ship that was
attacked by Pirates and Kuma being the
PowerHouse he is makes the pirate
surrender I got to say Kuma's devil
fruit powers that let him pretty much
teleport anywhere make him the perfect
tool for fixing problems like this think
about it wherever there's an issue Kuma
can just appear in moments and solve it
it reminds me how overpowered this fruit
is especially when used by someone so
strong and that makes sense since this
was a prize alongside kaido's mythical
Zone fruit and we know how special that
one is but that's not even the most
broken fruit of the chapter as we'll get
into near the end of this video for now
we're told that during the entire
chapter we have narration from Kuma's
letters to Bonnie the letters talk about
how Kuma loves Bonnie and he also talks
about the many beautiful and amazing
islands where they will travel together
in the future obviously he knows they
won't get the chance because he'll lose
his mind and free will but he talks
about them as if they will get to visit
them together in order to cheer up
Bonnie however we then cut to sorbet
Kingdom and we see that Kuma's letters
are being intercepted and even destroyed
by Alpha which just seems unnecessarily
cruel I know that maybe there could be
secret codes of breakout plans and stuff
from their perspective but Bonnie is
less than 10 years old it just seems so
innocent that it infuriates me all the
more not that we needed more reason to
be infuriated by the world government
thus we got a situation where kid Bonnie
is waiting for Kuma's letters every day
because he said he'd write them but from
her perspective they never arrive it's
heartbreaking stuff making it seem like
her father has forgotten about her but
don't worry I know we're all mad I know
we're all fuming right now but don't
worry Alpha will get her Just Desserts
before the chapter is over I promise we
then get a reveal that I love it turns
out that Bonnie never actually revealed
her Toshi Toshi no me AKA age age fruit
powers to Alpha and the medical team
Connie instructed her to keep her powers
a secret and then she drops one of my
favorite quotes to date she says and a
quote a smart Hawk must always hide its
claws end quote awesome quote and it
plays into the story beautifully right
now it's almost as good as that quote an
awesome human must always smash that
like button Jokes Aside though Kuma
visits Vega Punk's laboratory and we see
him meeting stussy's clone who will just
refer to as Stussy moving forward Stussy
says I wonder who is more unfortunate a
human with no consciousness or a clone
with Consciousness end quote but Vega
Punk brings her back to reality real
quick not entertaining her teenager
likee brooding he says enough Stussy I
told you that you are a human Mega Punk
by the way already has his apple head
here he explains that once the
modification is completed Kuma won't
have any memories or emotion left so
clearly Kuma's the one that's worth all
however regga Punk says that he will
keep Kuma's Consciousness up until the
very last minute and one year remains
until the surgery is completed and as we
saw good guy VAP Punk seemed to do even
better than that and stored Kuma's
memories in the form of one of his giant
paw bubbles we do see Kuma helping the
Revolutionary Army from time to time
talk about a conflict of interest for a
government worker but now he is
completely silent and never talks to
them dragon and his other friends know
there must be a reason behind Kuma's
strange Behavior but now to the truly
crazy Stu back to sorb Kingdom and
Bonnie is celebrating her 9th birthday
Kuma's letters still haven't arrived
then we're told one year passed since
Bonnie's surgery ended and so Bonnie is
now 100% healed however Alpha won't let
Bonnie go until her 10th birthday now at
first glance this is sort of what Bonnie
expected that she'd be cured by 10 but
then Connie gets some shocking info from
a local Town bar one member of the
medical team lets it slip that Alpha and
the other medical team members are world
government agents that's when Connie and
the people of sorbet Kingdom realize
something's wrong and accordingly they
begin to plan for Bonnie's Escape so the
strongest fisherman from sorb Kingdom
will take Bonnie to the Sea and help her
find Kuma they remodeled a fisherman's
ship into a pirate ship and decorated to
look like pizza for Bonnie suddenly her
ship design makes so much more sense now
that we know she's only around 10ish
Connie and Bonnie switch closed and
Bonnie steps outside for the first time
Bonnie gets past the guards and reaches
the ship however Alpha realizes she is
Bonnie and chases her using Geto Alpha
says in case you try to escape I'm
allowed to beat you up and restrain you
and this is where we get to the shocking
stuff Bonnie in child form recalls one
day when she asks Kuma what NAA looks
like Kuma says he's not really sure all
he knows that his body has a rubber
quality and he can fight any way he
wants then she uses her attack
Distortion future and thinks of a future
where she can be like na so keep in mind
this is all way before Luffy awakened
his powers in The Epic panel we see
Bonnie punching Alpha with a giant punch
like Luffy's gear three take that Alpha
I told you she get her Just Desserts
then B escapes sorb Kingdom and wow I'm
not even surprised she became a
supernova as a kid anymore she literally
beat a special agent and has arguably
the most broken fruit of all think about
it using distorted future she can
potentially adopt any devil fruit power
it's crazy when you think about it the
narrator tells us that the world
government immediately becomes aware of
the hostage Bonnie's Escape then we're
told we see her fisherman ship turned
into a pirate ship of the new era
rivaling Luffy and the other pirates
from that gener genertion and if you
love other characters with broken powers
like Bonnie then you won't want to miss
my recent Oda finally revealed chs's
true identity and Powers video link on
screen right now like And subscribe to
help us reach that insane Milestone of 2
million subscribers here on YouTube and
I'll see you in the next one